this is forbes's top creators list of
2023 and here are the top 10 richest
influencers of this year number 10 Brent
Rivera Brent Rivera has mastered several
of the world's most popular social media
platforms starting with Vine then
YouTube and finally Tick Tock where his
comedic videos which often feature his
younger sister Lexi Now command an
audience of 50 million fans but the 25
year old streamy award winner is as much
a businessman as he is a Creator having
partnered with Brands as big as
Starbucks Xbox and Prada and his
brainchild amp Studios a media company
he started in 2017 to teach other
creators and emerging brand how to go
viral is growing to focus on building IP
and other Ventures from the cpg to
immersive dining experiences
number nine Matt Rife comedian Matt Rife
became a major viral moment in 2023 as
clips of him interacting with live
audience members and clapping back at
hecklers Drew in millions of viewers
he's translated that audience into Real
World Sales selling out 7 500 000 seats
for a nationwide Comedy Tour releasing
his second stand-up special Matthew
Stephen Rife in April and yet another
titled walking red flag a show focusing
on just his audience interactions in
June
number eight Emma Chamberlain
since filming YouTube videos in her
mother's house Emma Chamberlain dropped
out of high school amassed 27.9 million
followers and turned her dry humor in
penshop for fashion into an Empire Emma
Chamberlain was one of the first
creators to secure a high fashion deal
with Louis Vuitton and has continued to
Ink lucrative deals well into 2023
including Partnerships with Cartier
Lancome Levi's aritzia and Canon her
Beverage Company Chamberlain coffee
retails at Walmart and sprouts and her
podcast anything goes began an exclusive
Spotify video deal in February
number seven Jerry original meme
King Eliot tebula the brain Behind
Popular meme aggregation account
Jerry first expanded from posting to
product with the card game what do you
meme which sold nationwide at Target
Walmart and Amazon tabbola's Ventures
have since included his own tequila
brand haha whose marketing is positioned
as a spoof casamigos an advertising
company Jerry media and a heating pad
the menstruation crustacean number six
Logan Paul
Logan Paul first went viral on Vine with
his brother Jake using that momentum to
open his YouTube
the channel has drawn 23.6 million
subscribers but Paul's alarming and
insensitive videos led him to become
demonetized on the platform so the
Creator took his knack for shock value
and pivoted into wrestling he re-signed
his WWE deal this year and has continued
to promote Prime hydration alongside
YouTuber KSI Paul also hosts a podcast
with his brother called impulsive where
they address continued controversy
number five Charlie demilio
Charlie's Emilio continues to reign
supreme as the top female Creator on
Tick Tock and on this list and the
demelio Dynasty is only growing larger
the Connecticut native now one of the
most viral stars on the internet has
become a face of Prada and a walking
advertisement for Amazon CeraVe skins
the clothing line co-founded by Kim
Kardashian and other leading Brands
similio's year old fragrance born
dreamer is on shelves across the U.S and
Europe and on racks you'll find Social
tourists which she and her sister Dixie
launched with Hollister in 2021 when the
family isn't shooting the third season
of their reality series The demelio Show
for Hulu they're busy getting their
recently launched shoe Empire demelio
Footwear off the ground and all that
before Charlie's even turned 20. number
four Rhett and Link
best friends since grade school the two
former Engineers real name Rhett James
McLaughlin and Charles Lincoln link Neil
III began posting comedy shows on
YouTube in 2011. today there are Burbank
California entertainment company
Mythical employs More than a hundred
people who create YouTube series like
the daily variety show Good Mythical
Morning the mythical kitchen cooking
series and the sketch comedy channel
Smosh for their 18 million subscribers
the pair produces podcasts and lives on
its two their online store Hawks
merchandise ranging from hoodies to
kitchen tools to toiletries
number three Jake Paul
the outrage cycle is no stranger to Jake
Paul the vine star turned boxer Who
stuns on YouTube surprise tattoos eating
dog food bathing an icy hot landed him a
slew of controversies for her sexual
assault scam allegations and most
recently an SEC charge for undisclosed
cryptocurrency sponsorship still Paul's
ability to orchestrate spectacle made
him one of the highest paid athletes in
2022. he landed a sponsorship with
energy drink Celsius founded sport
betting app better that raised 50
million dollars series a and this year
signed an MMA contract to fight in a new
pay-per-view division number two KSI
known as KSI began reacting to FIFA
video games in 2009 on YouTube
attracting millions of followers for his
outlandish humor the Creator soon
pivoted into rapping and boxing
releasing two singles in 2023 and
securing a multi-year distribution deal
for his promotional company Misfits
boxing he's the face of prime hydration
alongside Logan Paul which became the
official drink for FC Barcelona UFC and
Arsenal this year controversy has
followed Olatunji for boxing decorum
misogynistic content and racist and
transphobic slurs but he always turns it
into views whether online or in the ring
and coming in at number one Mr Beast Mr
Beast following is almost as large as
the entire population of the United
States the YouTube Giant and mega
Creator whose real name is Jimmy
Donaldson has snatched the top spot on
this list for the second year in a row
not only because of his enormous
audience but also because he has spun
that online clout into a real world
Empire yes it's hard to look away from
his high production videos of outrageous
stunts and surprise giveaways which
recently earned him a coveted streamy
award for the creator of the year but
Donaldson's brand extends far beyond
that to his sprawling merch line the
feastables candy bars that are available
across the U.S and UK and Mr Beast
Burgers restaurant chain it remains to
be seen how an ongoing legal feud
between Donaldson and the ghost kitchen
operator behind his Burgers will affect
the food Empire